Sciences breakthrough of the year for
2012 is the discovery of a subatomic
particle called the eight spokes which
grab headlines all over the world this
July choosing this as the breakthrough
of the year was easy explaining it is a
little more challenging let's just say
rarely have so many been so excited
about something quite so esoteric let's
begin with a little refresher on
particle physics all the matter around
us consists of quantum particles atoms
consists of particles called electrons
which was around the nucleus the nucleus
consists of protons and neutrons and the
protons and neutrons themselves consists
of quantum particles called quarks in
the 1960s and the 1970s physicists
developed a theory called the standard
model that describes all these particles
and heavier versions of them that can be
created in collisions at atom smashers
but there was one problem according to
the standard model all particles had to
be massless that's because if you
assigned mass to the particles the
theory would go mathematically haywire
so somehow mass has to come from the
interaction of otherwise massless
particles themselves and that's where
the Higgs comes in in 1964 Peter Higgs
and several other theorists realize that
if space is threaded with a field a bit
like an electric field then particles
can interact with it to gain energy and
thanks to Einstein's equation e equals
MC squared that will give them mass this
so-called Higgs mechanism is now
physicists explanation of how all
fundamental particles get their mass
just as an electric field consists of
quantum particles called photons
this new higgs field in the vacuum
should consist of quantum particles
called Higgs bosons to see one directly
you have to blast it out of the vacuum
in a violent particle collision and
that's what physicists seemed to have
done earlier this year physicists
working with the world's biggest atom
smasher the 27 kilometer long Large
Hadron Collider in Switzerland reported
that they had seen a particle that looks
every bit like the Higgs boson
the discovery of the Higgs boson if
that's what this new particle really is
fulfills a decades-old prediction and it
completes the standard model in that no
other particles are needed to make the
theory internally consistent but it
raises a big question will physicists
ever score another discovery like this
one they know that the standard model
can't be the final word in fundamental
physics it doesn't even incorporate the
force of gravity but when the Higgs in
the bag
they don't have a clear prediction of
what to look for next
[Music]